let's deal in joe concha fox news
joe how can they say this
when the vote had absolutely nothing to
do with race and everything with parents
wanting their kids to go to school and
not wanting a school board distracted by
oh i don't know renaming schools when
the kids aren't learning anything
right renaming schools such as
schools named after george washington
you know the guy won the revolutionary
war and abraham lincoln the guy who
freed the slaves yeah that that made
sense thankfully uh parents push back on
that ridiculous notion too but the
author of this piece her name is nicole
hemmer no relation to bill hammer we
must make that very clear
right and she says quote in places like
loudoun county in san francisco
conservative activists are attempting to
do the same today refashioning a suite
of school discontents into a wave of
republican victories unquote
she makes this argument in loudoun
county and san francisco as if they're
bastions of right-wing conservative
sentiment yet joe biden won loudoun
county with 61 percent of the vote in
virginia and took san francisco with 86
percent of the vote all right so
this is a far left ivy league scholar
saying that parents rights and that
movement in education is really a dark
far-right effort as we saw in virginia
and glenn younkin and his victory there
he ran on parents rights and education
and now here in the land of nancy pelosi
in san francisco education is an issue
that eviscerates party lines parents
care about what their kids are being
taught they're worried like me that the
us is 25th in the world in reading
writing science and math and perhaps
many of them me included don't want our
kids to view the world through the prism
of race maybe we just want our kids to
be best prepared to compete in the real
world by teaching them first just the
basic blocking and tackling that is
needed through reading math and science
and this is why democrats are in serious
trouble come the midterms this
disconnect and now they're seen as the
anti-parent party and of course cnn is
going to publish this sort of stuff
because they're disconnected as well
speaking of disconnected joe joy behar
said this on the view yesterday about
masks watch this
personally i listen to the little voice
in my head
that doesn't really follow 100 what they
tell me because they keep changing it i
would wear a mask and i might do that
indefinitely i don't think it's 100 safe
yet
and you know honestly fine it's great
everybody can wear a mask if they want
not wear a mask but
you know her rule i guess is apparently
follow the science until the science
says you could take your mask off
right and the science says that
yesterday new york city averaged let's
see about 100 coveted cases all right
that's a city of 8 million that number
was 40 000 just one month ago so so
covet is drastically down in terms of
transmission in terms of spread local
indoor mass mandates are being dropped
except in schools of course we can't
have that it's sarcasm friday by the way
in case anybody didn't understand that
tone uh but but i i just find it so
ironic here you have behar and three
other women talking about the importance
of masks yet they're sitting around a
table indoors talking to each other for
an hour without one so look this is the
type of covert panic porn that america
has become absolutely sick and tired of
and until you can actually find somebody
from the right or at least right of
center that can make a decent argument
at that table and push back on behar
ratings at the view are going to
continue to plummet for that show it's
simply just an echo chamber at this
point and it was a lot more interesting
when megan mccain was there that i can
tell you you know when joy behar refers
to that little voice inside her head i
imagine it's some combination of the
domino's noid you remember him and the
little whammy guy from press your luck
do you agree
what's pressure luck that sounds like
something from the 80s or something
that's before carly in my time that's
for sure
look it up we gotta leave it here thank
you